notre invité politique ce matin c'est
david cormand bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous député
européen europe ecologie les verts on va
balayer ensemble l'actualité on commence
évidemment par la crise sanitaire
s'aérer pour souffler se distancier pour
se protéger c'est ainsi qu'olivier vers
en lice de la santé résume ce nouveau
confinement dont il ne veut pas dire le
nom
est ce que le gouvernement a trouvé le
bon équilibre sur ces nouvelles mesures
en tout cas là il ya une impression je
crois qu'il partage et de confusion de
la part du message qui est adressé aux
françaises et aux français cette
confusion avec les mois qui se succèdent
elle devient elle devient insupportable
parce que c'est depuis le début quand
même moi je trouve que les gens sont
très comment dire docile il faut grosso
modo globalement il ya des exceptions
mais globalement ils font ce qu'on leur
demande
il accepte le fait qu'ils me part
d'incertitude c'est normal on est face à
un virus qu'on connaissait pas qu'on
connaît un peu mieux
il ya maintenant la firme des variants
et donc je trouve que les gens sont
plutôt oui obéissant ils font de leur
mieux et on a face à un gouvernement qui
font qu'ils s'aiment plus de
l'incertitude qui sèment davantage de
doutes que que du fait de rassurer tout
ça donc ça c'est ça commence un peu à
être être pénible
l'autre élément moi qui me qui me pose
problème c'est que quand même cette
crise elle met un éclairage assez crue
sur le fait que les moyens de l'état les
moyens de service public ont été
abandonnés ou laissés de côté depuis
longtemps et là on en paye un peu la
facture et cette crise depuis un an
quand même ça fait un an qu'on est
confronté à cela que ça on le sait que
ce diagnostic là il a été posé et j'ai
pas l'impression qu'à une prise de
conscience de ce point de vue là de dire
il faut remuscler au service public des
vivres animations accompagner davantage
le secteur hospitalier la croix il ya un
ségur de la santé qui est qui est mis en
place un et des revalorisations
salariales et jean castex et à quelques
jours a annoncé un plan de 19 milliards
d'euros justement pour remuscler bande à
l'aise que pour vous c'est pas suffisant
parce que le nombre de lits continue
bc ou de stagner alors qu'on voit bien
que c'est sur ce critère là en partie
sur ce critère là qu'on décide ou pas de
de faire les confinements et le degré de
confinement l'hôte élément qui m'a
étonné par exemple c'est de continuer
regardez sur le télétravail à dire on
demande aux entreprises de faire des
efforts ça fait des mois qu'on dit qu'il
faut que le ski entre de faim les lieux
de contamination s'est beaucoup les
lieux de travail et les transports
publics en partie si on encourage plus
qu'encourageants n'impose le télétravail
sa limite ces lieux de contamination on
est toujours dans une logique un peu
aidé logique d'ailleurs qui est de dire
on n'oblige pas on demande aux
entreprises
poliment de faire les choses c'est à
dire qu'il faut plus de sanctions plus
de contrôle vous le rende obligatoire
faut dire le télétravail c'est
obligatoire points 5 jours tant que oui
et tankers je sais bien que pour un
certain nombre de salariés ça à d'autres
inconvénients mais enfin rester dans
cette espèce d'entre eux deux depuis des
mois en fait c'est quand même fort c'est
pénible
donc voilà en quoi je suis un peu dans
un entre-deux et sur fond clair que
c'est pas clair on comprend pas bien
alors on nous promet qu'il faut tenir
quinze jours de plus trois semaines de
plus je suis patient qu'on a
complètement pris en compte la
modélisation de ce qu'implique le
variant blake est plus contagieux qui
touchent plus gravement d'autres types
de publics de population que le variant
précédent donc voilà j'ai l'impression
que sa dans la semoule kouadio
est ce que vous diriez comme christian
jacob le patron des républicains que ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle c'est
l'échec personnel du chef de l'état qui
en est le seul responsable
je pense que ce que j'ai tout à l'heure
sur l'abandon du service public qui a
pas que l'actuel président de la
république quand on est responsable et
d'ailleurs la famille politique de
monsieur jacob n'est pas complètement
innocente en la matière après là où il
ya la gauche elle est née quand elle
était aux affaires
ces tentes et qu'elle a été de gauche
quand elle l'était mais ça c'est un
autre débat non par contre là où c'est
vrai c'est que le chef de l'état a voulu
prendre sur lui c'est le roi thaumaturge
e vous savez qui est présenté comme un
expert en épidémiologie il est tout ce
qui passe au franc on en fait enfin la
majorité en faire un portrait quasiment
surhumain avec le fait c'était son
fameux paris le fait de
quelques semaines je vais pas confiné
donc là il ya une responsabilité un peu
individuelle qui est de refuser
d'écouter l'intelligence collective et
notamment de ceux qui savent le conseil
scientifique les épidémiologique qui ait
lieu avait annoncé depuis plusieurs
semaines qu'on allait être aujourd'hui
dans cette situation là donc là il ya
une responsabilité particulière mais
qu'est liée à la personnalité des
manuels macro et et ce à sa conception
de ce que doit être le pouvoir que je ne
partage pas à un mot sur une région que
vous connaissez bien la normandie et ce
confinement de la seine maritime et de
l'eure confinement un peu surprise il
que même edouard philippe a critiqué ce
qu'il a eu raison
bah je pense qu'il a un peu mal pris
parce que en dehors du fait qu'il est le
maire d'une ville importante de la seine
maritime qui est le havre est un peu
l'ancien premier ministre et de ce que
j'ai compris de sa réaction il a même
pas eu un coup de fil de courtoisie pour
lui dire bon voilà et c'est vrai que ça
nous est un peu tombé dessus alors après
quand on regarde les chiffres il ya pas
de scandale effectivement l'eure et la
seine-maritime ont des chiffres qui sont
comparables aux autres départements
qu'on lui ce tour de vis supplémentaire
mais c'est toujours un peu désagréable
de subir les choses sans avoir été
informé avant surtout que dans
l'application de ces restrictions le
fait de s'allier avec les collectivités
locales et les élus locaux
d'abord ça permet d'améliorer
l'efficacité parce qu'on anticipe les
choses puissent et améliore aussi
l'acceptabilité de ces affaires classe
ça tombe un peu c'est la foudre
jupitérienne qui ça va et on pourrait
faire autrement encore très franchement
sur l'attestation parce qu des couacs 1
ce week-end autour de cette attestation
elle a été publiée sur deux pages
finalement elle a été retirée qu'est-ce
que sa rivale selon vous quand mais la
ccc l'embolie de la toute-puissance
technocratique qui en plus que j'ai tout
à l'heure se décline par très peu de
services humains au bout de la chaîne et
donc il ya des gens je ne sais pas leur
métier ils sont dans des bureaux ils
inventent des trucs invraisemblables et
en plus c'est du temps de travail chez
lui non plus que c'est des gens
intelligents il devrait pourrait
peut-être être mieux utilisé à la faire
autre chose et tout ça pour au bout de
quelques heures dire ben tout ça n'a
aucun sens en très franchement où les
sallèlois une forme d'un préparation
alors d'une part et aussi une forme de
huit sentiment de toute puissance de la
part voilà deux hauts fonctionnaires
lors avec moi j'aime beaucoup les
fonctionnaires il s'en fout mais au
moins qu'on les utilise à quelque chose
d'utile et puis autre chose c'est que en
mars dernier quand on était confronté
pour la première fois ces règles de
confinement la vertu pédagogique d'avoir
un papier pour que les gens comprennent
qu'on sort pas n'importe comment ça
pouvait s'entendre là les gens sont pas
crétin quand même ils ont compris que ce
que ses volières se confiner et je
conçois pas bien d'infantiliser les gens
et d'en rajouter alors c'était une page
au départ mais au bout d'un moment on va
faire un truc de deux pages pour être
sûr qu'on vous explique bien fait
personne ne comprend rien et c'est un
peu méprisant vis-à-vis des gens et donc
je pense que le fait d'avoir pris la
décision d'hier avec votre carte
d'identité ça suffit franchement c'est
des trucs un peu de bon sens il me
semble mais voilà l'autre question qui
se pose c'est celle de la vaccination
hier la maire de paris anne hidalgo elle
a appelé à débrider la vaccination à
l'ouvrir à tous ceux qui le souhaitent
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
tout le monde dit ça le problème c'est
que personne n'est contre débrider la
vaccination alors pour le gouvernement
pour le moment le gouvernement reste
dans sa stratégie de d'âge de
priorisation des grandes vérités assez
de vaccins
c'est ça le problème c'est pas la
volonté de dire il faut vacciner plus -
machin assez qu'on gère une pénurie au
gère une pénurie de vaccins ce alors que
la capacité de vaccination technique
elle pourra être augmentée le problème
c'est qu'il faut enfin c'est d'une
simplicité enfantine il faut des doses
de vaccin pour pouvoir vacciner les gens
or là il ya un problème c'est qu'on a
europe singulièrement depuis plusieurs
années encore une fois abandonné notre
capacité de production en avant mais
aussi autre chose c'est la recherche cir
concédé charger complètement sur des
grands laboratoires européens qui
existent ou c'était à eux de choisir sol
là où il a été de la recherche comment
ils organisaient leur production comme
ils délocalisent est elle partie tel
autre parti c'est vrai qu'on a perdu une
forme on utilise le mot de souveraineté
va dire est simplement d'autonomie
sanitaire au niveau européen et ça c'est
une logique politique est derrière
si une logique une forme de libéralisme
mondialisé où au fond c'est pas très
grave que ça soit produit l'un à l'autre
bout du monde
tout ça n'est pas très grave les
échanges internationaux vont nous
permettre de compenser ça et là en fait
on se rend compte qu'en période de crise
c'est pas ça qui se passe est donc là
leur chance pour moi c'est que 1
l'union se fasse respecter la part des
laboratoires que nous avons subventionné
et que nous avons financé en pré
achetant des labours des des récents
essais pas le cas à l'heure actuelle
elle m'a respectée l'union européenne
passées passé par exemple le fait de
s'arc-bouter sur le secret des contrats
et ce secret des contrats il est à l
avantage des entreprises c'est pas un
avantage des citoyens ou l'union c'est
parce que les entreprises nous le
demande l'on demandé à la commission que
la commission a accepté de faire ce
secret et a tenu toujours aujourd'hui
n'aiment pas rendre publiques ces
contrats donc ça c'est déjà un premier
scandale là maintenant je pense qu'il
faut poser la question clairement de la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins nous
avons en partie financée pour eux pour
le coup débrider la production et puis
fait ce que là pour le coup il ya besoin
de la débrider la production avait
entendu thierry breton qui répète depuis
plusieurs jours que l'union européenne
sera le premier continent à produire des
vaccins il parle de 2 milliards de doses
qui seront produites dans l'union
européenne qu'est ce que ça va changer
la levée des brevets est ce que la
production à travers les bretons si j'ai
bien compris il a dit que ça serait pour
le deuxième trimestre 6 ème trimestre
est pas tout de suite hein c'est
jusqu'au mois et je trouve ça très drôle
alors qu'il donne l'aval du 14 juillet
comme si le 14 juillet avait une
résonance européenne
je confie de le dire pour nous les
françaises qu'attendu et c'est très
important mais pas le reste de l'europe
n'est pas sûr que l'europe doivent
calqué son calendrier sur l'a4 nationale
française mais au-delà de ça j'ai dit
hier monsieur breton il a fait du damage
control est il a dit ce qu'on dit depuis
des semaines depuis des mois encore un
petit peu de patience vous verrez dans
trois mois
ça ira mieux nous les verts niveau
européen ça fait des semaines et même
des mois qu'on demande la transparence
qu'on demande de récupérer ses brevets
et d'organiser de stratégie c'est le
fait de rapatrier la production sur
l'ensemble des sites qui peuvent le
faire au niveau européen de le faire en
urgence sans attendre le feu vert des
laboratoires que nous avons encore une
fois co financer avec de l'argent public
c'est l'argent public donc on parle
quand il parle de 300 à 350 millions de
doses qui seront livrés à l'union
européenne d'ici la fin de l'été d'ici
la fin avant la fin de l'été d'ici le
mois de juin vous y croyez mais j'espère
après 350 millions de doses alors j'ai
pas compris d'ailleurs si c'était des
doses où il en fait les deux pour
certains vaccins ou quoi parce que c'est
évidemment pas pareil parce que c'est
700 cc 350 millions de vaccins en tout
350 injection ça j'ai pas bien compris
le selon t il retourner c'est un peu
juste c'est un peu juste pour l'ensemble
des habitants européen et c'est surtout
un peu juste et c'est l'autre facteur
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit pour aider
les pays du sud qui eux n'ont pas les
moyens d'avoir accès à ces vaccins est
là
l'union européenne a une responsabilité
particulière nous sommes un continent
riche puissant et on peut pas imaginer
qu'on va se vacciner nous dans notre
bulle et abandonner le reste du monde
donc voilà transparence sur les contrats
récupérer les brevets et favoriser la
production massive et aider les pays de
l'est ce que transparence c'est aussi
tapé plus de poing sur la table avec les
labos est-ce qu'il faut bloquer les
exportations par exemple oui c'est une
des solutions qui a envisagée après vous
rentrez dans facile gestion de la
pénurie sûr qu'en fait c'est dire on va
pas vous laisser livrés pour que nous on
en est plus ici
si on doit en arriver là pourquoi pas
mais c'est ça serait pour moi un aveu
des chèques la question c'est de
produire énormément énormément de
vaccins très vite et que comment dire la
façon de temporiser de laboratoires ne
se ne contraint pas à ne pas pouvoir
sauver des vies parce que c'est une
affaire de vie ou de mort dont on parle
un dernier mot sur thierry breton hier
il a fermé un peu la porte aux vaccins
spoutnik ville a dit que l'union
européenne en avait pas besoin d'eux est
d'accord avec ça je suis pas dogmatique
là dessus soit il fonctionne et donc les
agences de santé qui ont fait passer des
tests
d'autres vaccins faut passer les mêmes à
se motiver et le fait est qu'ils
marchent dans ce cas là il n'y a pas de
raison de s'en priver
soit ils marchent moins bien il faut
expliquer en quoi et dans ce cas là on
sent pris mais là encore une fois je
pense qu'il faut pas faire de la
géopolitique mal placé si l'union
européenne veut faire du rapport de
force avec la russie alors la raison de
le faire
c'est pas en nous publie sans nous même
d'un vaccin qui éventuellement
fonctionnerait bien ça à un autre niveau
que cela se joue une dernier mot sur la
stratégie vaccinale de nuit en peine en
gala merkel a dit que l'allemagne est
elle privilégiera la commande de
européenne mais que si elle n'arrive pas
elle commandera de son côté est ce que
la france doit faire la même chose
oui pour l'instant elle le dit elle ne
le fait pas parce qu'il faut comprendre
que les chefs d'état sont soumis à la
pression des différentes populations de
leurs pays respectifs et il vous a
peut-être pas échapper qu'en allemagne
dans quelques mois il y aura une
élection donc tout le monde
tout ça n'est que politique pour vous
c'est en parti politique et moi je
voudrais pas comment dire qu'on fasse un
mauvais procès à l'union heureusement
l'union européenne a pris l'initiative
alors que ce n'est pas sa compétence à
la santé de groupe et ses commandes ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher c'est d'être
resté au milieu du guet de ne pas avoir
été jusqu'au bout de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
imposer un rapport de forces au
laboratoire mais moi je suis
reconnaissant à l'union d'avoir quand
même pris cette initiative
sinon on serait dans une situation qui
est encore le pire donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut rester sur cette stratégie
européenne il fonda qu'on commande de
telles conditions
l'union fasse le job jusqu'au bout sa
sas et il ya une obligation de moyens
mais aussi une obligation de résultat de
la porte de l'union bruxelles qui a
présenté la semaine dernière son projet
de certificats verts numérique c'est une
sorte de passeport vaccinale pour
faciliter les voyages au sein d'une
européenne est ce que vous êtes
favorable aujourd'hui au moment où on
parle on vient de parler pendant de
longues minutes de la pénurie de vaccins
de penser à imposer un passeport je sais
qu'il faut pas utiliser le terme et
c'est de ça dont on parle sanitaires à
la population c'est quand même un peu
pas piquée des hannetons fière que l'un
des gens ils demandent à être vaccinés
on va pas en plus leur demander d'avoir
un passeport alors qu'ils demandent que
ça d'être vaccinées au moment où il y
aura des accents pour tout le monde tout
le monde pour ceux qui savent et qui le
souhaitent auront pu être vaccinés bois
réfléchir une sorte de laisser passer
mais moi j'ai pas très soucieux de la
forme que ça prendra par exemple je
serai très hostile que ce passeport soit
mis vous savez sur l'application stop
qu'ovide pourquoi parce que quand cette
application a été mis en oeuvre moi
j'étais défavorable d'ailleurs parce que
je pense que la surveillance numérique
des populations pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire est une mauvaise piste mais il
avait été dit par les autorité éthique
que cette application ne devait pas lier
être lié à des restrictions si on a
téléchargé pas et donc si si c'est sur
ce support qu'on mettait ce passeport
sanitaires ou ce passeport le numérique
sanitaires là il y aurait une forme de
contrainte à la population de
télécharger cette application et je ne
crois pas qu'il faille est dans ce
registre après quand vous donne un
papier
si vous êtes vacciné et que vous
puissiez présenter ce papier quand je ne
sais pas quoi vous voyagez là vous devez
cesser à partir du moment où tout le
monde aura plus à taxi une dernière
question sur une européenne puisque lors
du conseil européen ne sera pas question
de la uniquement de la stratégie
vaccinale et sert aussi question de la
turquie au moment où erdogan vient de
quitter le traité européen contre les
violences faites aux femmes est ce qu'on
peut encore discuter avec la turquie
est ce que l'union européenne n'est pas
lâche avec la turquie la l'union
européenne elle est ambiguë avec la
turquie
pendant longtemps elle a eu des
pourparlers avec elle pour eux envisager
d'ailleurs l'entrée de la turquie en
europe depuis monsieur erdogan est
arrivé au pouvoir et pourquoi on a une
relation ambiguë avec la turquie
dans ce cas la fois qu'on exige d'elles
des normes éthiques sur les droits
humains et c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait
légitime mais en même temps on fait
appel à elle notamment pour réguler
entre guillemets avec quels moyens les
migrations et donc on est dans une
situation un peu particulière ou à la
fois on fait les gros yeux à la turquie
sur les droits humains mais d'une
manière un peu cynique on est bien
content qu'elle ne respecte pas les
droits humains pour maltraiter les
migrants qui souhaitent rejoindre notre
continent notamment faut savoir soit on
est attaché aux droits humains et on a
un discours cohérent sur toute la ligne
soit on n'y pas attaché il a fait
rentrer aujourd'hui les européens pour
vous bah c'est oui
il faut trancher les choses mais c'est
pas sur les questions d'immigration je
pense qu'on les trouvera pas à ce coup
ci c'est monsieur erdogan fait partie
des dirigeants du monde d'aujourd'hui
qui font la démagogie de la surenchère
sur ces questions là qui veulent
afficher une forme d'autorité par
rapport à leur population et donc faut
appréhender ce risque nouveau qui
corresponde pas effectivement valeur de
lune on va passer au reste de
l'actualité en france l'assemblée
nationale qui a voté largement le texte
permettant de modifier la constitution
pour y inscrire la garantie de la
protection de l'environnement
le texte va maintenant arriver au sénat
sauf que le sénat ne veut pas du terme
garantir est ce que si le sénat vote
pour le terme préservé par exemple vous
diriez bon c'est un bon compromis
non je pense que le terme garantir il
est vital parce que c'est celui qui
permet de faire en sorte qu'elle ne plus
value par rapport aux textes déjà
existants ça responsabilise
juridiquement dans la loi des loisirs
sell qui ensuite dirige les autres le
fait qu'il ya une responsabilité non pas
d'obligation de moyens
encore une fois mais d'obligation de
résultat c'est une garantie comme quand
vous signez un contrat ou acheter une
télé il ya une garantie on vous garantit
donc si les mots ont un sens et de le
conseil d'état il va dans le sens des
sénateurs est ce que ce n'est pas en
train de donner raison à la version du
sénat plutôt non mais je pense que le
conseil d'état y là comment dire il a
une lecture qui est la sienne moi je
pense que les parlementaires ils doivent
c'est eux qui ont le dernier mot en la
matière et qu'il faut tenir sur ce terme
de garantir après la situation dans
laquelle on est nous ne découvrons pas
c'était le coup de jarnac si je veux
dire le chef de l'état depuis le départ
qui mettait dans les pattes du sénat le
fait de soi accepter sa formulation et
la formulation du conseil commence bien
et c'était une victoire pour lui soit
refusé à la formulation il pouvait se
décharger sur le scénar et envoyez moi
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
donc c'est quand même plus de yara dans
sa bande de l'état je pense quand même
qu'il n'y croit pas vraiment son
référendum
je pense que pour lui le conçoit comme
un coup politique il ne conçoit pas
comme quelque chose d'existant ciel
l'essentiel pour l'avenir de la vie sur
terre de nos sociétés et c'est un peu le
problème qu'on avait de la relation des
manuels
avec l'écologie l'écologie c'est pas un
truc pour faire joli c'est pas un truc
pour faire des concours d'éloquence
c'est quelque chose qui est encore une
fois un vital existentielle à l'avenir
de la vie sur terre et donc faut prendre
ces sujets là au sérieux est ce que ne
fait pas emmanuel tu crois pas l'autre
actualité ce sont ses propos il ya
quelques jours sur europe 1 de la
présidente de l'unef cette organisation
étudiante a évoqué l'organisation de
réunions interdites aux blancs pour
permettre aux personnes touchées par le
racisme de ces d'exprimer ce qu'elle
subit ce qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
de ces propos de ses pratiques non mois
déjà ce qui m'a choqué c'est l'interview
je désire vous êtes désolé de le dire
c'est que cette jeune femme qui est
responsable d'un syndicat étudiant les
étudiants aujourd'hui qui vivent une
situation comme l'ensemble des
françaises et des français d'ailleurs
qui n'est pas simple c'est pour parler
de la précarité étudiante
pourquoi je parle de ça parce que c'est
très symptomatique de l'espèce
d'ambiance délétère qu'on a dans le
débat public et or sur treize minutes
d'interview et une deux minutes sur la
situation de précarité des étudiants et
le reste du temps sur le procès en islam
au gauchisme en politique je sais plus
quoi des colonials en vraiment à charge
et double en l'occurrence est-ce que
c'est pas une question qui se pose est
ce que ça vous a choqué vous sinon je
vous dire pourquoi ça me choque pas
c'est que depuis des années pendant que
vous êtes dans des milieux qui luttent
pour leur émancipation que ce soit les
personnes lgbt cuit que ce soit les
bébés et les femmes
que ce soit les personnes victimes
d'agression que ce soit les personnes
noirs ou arabes qui sont victimes de
racisme l'une des étapes dans la prise
de conscience et dans la capacité de
reprendre le pouvoir sur ce qui vous
arrive c'est de parler avec des
personnes qui ont vécu la même chose et
qui vivent la même chose que vous là où
il y aurait un problème et pour vivre ça
il faut forcément de ne pas être là où
il y aurait un problème c'est si on
restait en vase clos
le fait est là c'est le cas pour ce qui
concerne l'une fc en un an qui est une
deux réunions 1h ou 2h ou des personnes
ayant le terme interdit en voulant me
gêne parce que la réalité c'est que on
envoie un message en disant on va avoir
une réunion pour discuter de ces sujets
là celles qui se sentent concernés
viennent
et donc ces gens qui se sentent
concernés qui viennent discuter et
ensuite il ya évidemment une discussion
avec l'ensemble des autres militants
quel que soit leur origine ou que sage
et après il ya un dialogue avec la
société
mais réduire ces moments tous les
mouvements des massifs d'émancipation
des noirs aux états unis
on va m'accuser de dire ah oui c'est une
référence à la mairie et pourquoi vous
la fin par non aux etats unis le
mouvement d'émancipation des noirs
c'est quelque chose qu'il ne doit pas
être condamné et donc aujourd'hui on est
dans une sorte d'inversion des valeurs
ou les personnes qui luttent contre le
racisme sont taxés de racisme ou les
personnes qui sont victimes de
discriminations sont taxés d'être
victimaire et au fond de vouloir être
les bourreaux du reste de la société
cette inversion des valeurs ça fait le
jeu de clips mais est-ce que larges
extraits ce que là c'est pas une forme
de racisme de racisme anti blanc en
l'occurrence je crois pas au terme de
racisme anti blanc
non pas que il est pas des personnes qui
expriment verbales envers des blancs je
t'aime pas ou quoi ce qui évidemment
absurde
le terme de racisme pour moi je le
réserve aux situations comment dire
systémique c'est que dans une société de
façon systémique
quand vous êtes une certaine origine ou
quand vous avez une certaine apparence
dans toutes les activités de la vie ou
de beaucoup d'entre elles vous êtes
confrontés à un racisme ça c'est le cas
des noirs c'est le cas des arabes ces
cas des juifs c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre de la population et les blancs au
sens caucasien du terme si je veux dire
c'est moins le cas ça veut pas dire vous
n'êtes pas se pouvait pas être soumis à
une agression dans la rue mais elle est
ponctuelle à les graves ponctuelles
n'est pas systémique et donc le terme de
racisme anti blanc on peut l'utiliser si
on veut mais il faut se mettre d'accord
sur qu'est ce qu'on entend par racisme
et encore une fois c'est une façon de
mettre un signe égal entre des personnes
qui subissent ce type de discrimination
tout au long de leur vie
depuis des générations et des personnes
qui essaient très graves peuvent être
agressés à un moment ponctuelle il faut
évidemment sanctionné cela mais il ya
une confusion des thermes et il ya une
confusion des valeurs qui moi ma requête
est encore une fois je sais de qui ça
fait le jeu cela une dernière question
rapidement david cormand sur les
régionales puisque la question d'un
éventuel report port en fonction de
l'évolution de la crise sanitaire se
pose est ce que vous serez favorable à
ce rapport à ce stade non parce qu'il y
avait moyen d'anticiper les choses et
d'ailleurs c'est toujours le moment pour
pouvoir faire plus de des balles
télévision il ya des chaînes publiques
etc et surtout ce qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'avant même la crise sanitaire
le président de la république souhaitait
se débarrasser de ces élections locales
et de les repousser à après les
présidentielles
ce qui serait une grave entrave pour
vous la crise sanitaire c'est une excuse
encore je dirais pas que c'est une
excuse en tout cas visiblement ça
n'empêche pas de dormir ça les empêche
pas de dormir donc le truc c'est que moi
ce qui serait rédhibitoire
c'est qu'on repousse ces élections à
après les présidentielles parce que l'on
changerait la nature de ce scrutin
mais à l'automne vous seriez pas opposé
moi je pense que pour l'instant un peu
différent gelant merci beaucoup merci
david cormand d'avoir été à notre invité
ce matin et on passe ce titre au club
des territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
les transitions zéro carbone et région
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires comme tous les
lundis
[Musique]